And the time here always changes
on Saturday. Never changes on any other
day, so
always changes on a Saturday.
And I know a lot of people
expect an announcement.
However, sometimes I might forget to
announce, right? So, don't rely on that.
So, always
you know, rely on the WhatsApp when it
when it is is published, the calendar
that you keep an eye on it, set an
alarm, or set it a date in your phone
that it will alert you because I may
forget to announce it, and then the next
day you'll come and find that the time
has changed. So, every month, couple
days before the end of the month, the
schedule goes out.
Always make sure to mind those changes.
You guys know what to do.
You got it.
[Silence]
Continuing in
Al-Wajiz
in the book of fasting
we are in the book of fasting in the
chapter regarding the days in which
one is prohibited from fasting.
Yesterday we mentioned the two days of
Eid. So, two days of Eid
you know, often times Eid al-Adha
a lot of people view it as as being 3
days of Eid or 5 days of Eid. It is 1
day. Eid is technically 1 day. It is on
the 10th
and it is on the 1st. The 1st of
Shawwal, the 10th of Dhu al-Hijjah.
However,
there are other things that happen on
the major Eid which is which is at the
end of the year in the 12th month after
Hijrah.
And part of that is Ayyam al-Tashreeq.
Ayyam al-Tashreeq.
Hathihil Ayyam
hiya
[Arabic recitation]
al-Tashreeq
min shuruq al-shams.
Sabihatah.
Li annal insan
fil ghalib al-nas al-hujjaj yakhrujun
inda shuruq al-shams ba'dal fajri li
ramyil jamarat.
Fa summiyat Ayyam al-Tashreeq.
The next time is the time or the days of
al-Tashreeq. Al-Tashreeq is taken from
al-shuruq which is the break of dawn.
Right when
not the break of dawn, but the the
the rising of the sun and the the the
when the sun is most intense as it rises
after sunrise. And the reason that these
days are referred to that
referred to by that phenomenon is
that
usually that is the time when the people
that are in Hajj will go to throw their
jamarat. They would make Fajr
in Mina, and then they would go to
al-jamarat to throw their jamarat. And
so, this would happen
once the sun has risen a bit. So, the
these days are referred to as the days
of Tashreeq. And those days are the
11th, 12th, and 13th of Dhul-Hijjah.
So, we have one day, which is the Sunnah
to fast from Dhul-Hijjah. The next day,
which is haram to fast. And then the
following 3 days, which are
haram to fast, or prohibited to fast
according to the majority of the
scholarship of Islam.
So, the ninth is the Sunnah to fast, the
10th is haram to fast, the 11th, 12th,
and 13th
of one is prohibited from fasting as
well.
[Silence]
Mentions one of the Tabi'in mentions
that he went with Abdullah ibn Amr
to his father's house. So, Abu Murrah
was
a friend with Abdullah ibn Amr. And
Abdullah ibn Amr, his father, Amr ibn
al-As, a companion, as a matter of fact,
he's not just any companion. He is
single-handedly responsible for the
conquest of the West in his time, in the
time of Omar ibn al-Khattab. And so, he
went with Abdullah to his father's
house. And this was presumably during
the days of al-Tashreeq, 11th, 12th, or
13th, one of those days. And so,
Amr had food brought out for them to
eat.
And
Abu Murrah said, "I'm fasting."
And so, he said, "Eat
because these are days in which the
messenger of Allah sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would
consistently
command us to not fast during these
days. He would command us to
go, you know, to to particularly in
these days eat and prohibit us from
fasting."
And Imam Malik rahimahullah narrates
this narration.
He says, "And these days are the days of
al-Tashreeq that he was speaking about."
[Silence]
He said,
"And on the authority of Aisha and ibn
Omar, both who narrate that the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
had not allowed anyone make
anyone fast during the days of
al-Tashreeq except for someone who did
not have anything to slaughter
in Hajj, meaning someone who has to fast
3 days in Hajj and 7 days
after Hajj.
This is a kaffara or this is a part of
Hajj. It is very specific to the people
in Hajj only.
[Silence]
So, Allah mentions this specifically in
Surat al-Baqarah in a verse regarding
Hajj that
if a person does not have
a hady or an offering to make on the day
of the offerings, the day of
slaughtering, the day of the 10th of Dhu
al-Hijjah, then specifically that person
is to fast 3 days in Hajj and 7 after he
has returned home. 3 days in Hajj
meaning 11th, 12th, and 13th. This is
what Aisha and Ibn Umar understood the
verse to mean. And so, a person may fast
only in this instance.
We understand from this that outside of
this instance, it is not permissible to
fast. And in another narration that the
author didn't mention that the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam said
regarding
the days of at-tashreeq, "Hādhihi ayyāmu
akl in wa
These are days of eating and drinking
and remembrance of Allah.
Meaning the 11th, 12th, and 13th. So, it
is not permissible for a person to fast
during these days of the Tashriq
outside of certain very specific
circumstances. If a person were to fast
on these days the
a a large portion of the scholarship of
Islam view that fast to be
not only impermissible, but invalid.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]